today I want to talk about vitamin D and
a magnesium deficiency there's a very
interesting relationship between vitamin
D and magnesium that I think you should
know about especially since most of the
population is deficient in both vitamin
D and magnesium I think it's 75% of the
population has low vitamin D levels and
45% has low magnesium levels and here's
what you need to know all of the enzymes
involving the conversion of vitamin D to
the active form of vitamin D are
magnesium dependent that means if you're
completely zero with magnesium vitamin D
will not work period and we know how
important vitamin D is for bone for bone
pain for insulin resistance for your
immune system to prevent muscle cramps
cardiovascular problems with blood
pressure and fatigue so magnesium allows
vitamin D to work and vitamin D also
allows magnesium to be absorbed by a
factor of 30% so they're both
synergistically helping each other now
there's another mineral involved and
it's calcium if you're low in magnesium
you're going to have problems with that
calcium because not only does Vitamin D
help the absorption of calcium by 20% in
your gut but magnesium also helps
regulate calcium magnesium helps prevent
calcium from building up inside your
arteries magnesium is really good for
blood pressure and just having elastic
arteries to adapt to exercise and bounce
back from stress things like that and it
helps lower cortisol and it will help
you sleep so there's a certain ratio of
calcium to magnesium that someone needs
and roughly you need like twice as much
calcium as magnesium but nowadays this
ratio is really like three times as much
calcium as magnesium and The Simple
Solution is to increase your magnesium
but the problem is how do you do that
because the average person only consumes
like 1 and 1/2 cups of salad per day
it's not even probably the dark leafy
greens that's high in magnesium and also
like I think it's 83% of all the
calories in the grocery store are Ultra
processed and that's another way that
people are deficient in magnesium
because our foods are just stripped of
all the magnesium and when we have this
increase in calcium to a magnesium then
we start getting you know calcification
of the arteries it even can increase the
risk of different types of cancer
prostate col rectal it can increase
polyps which potentially could end up
going into a cancer state so I just
wanted to put this on your radar to make
sure you're having enough of magnesium
to allow vitamin D to work but also
don't forget about vitamin D you need
that as well now because of the
sensoring and the suppressing of the
algorithms on YouTube it's becoming more
difficult to find my content and there's
a lot of content that I cannot put on
YouTube unfortunately so to make sure
you have full access of all my
information go to drberg.com And
subscribe to my newsletter by clicking
the link Down Below in the description I
will see you on the other side and if
you have not seen my very popular video
I just released on magnesium that will
give you a lot more information I put
that video up right here check it
out